[Música]
turno de la actualidad cultural en
france 24 con los campos elíseos
coronados por un sueño hoy francia es
nuestro arranque obligado y es que a
comienzos de los 60 al artista christo
vladimiro javacheff le nación deseo de
envolver el arco del triunfo de parís ya
en esa década y siempre con ayuda de su
pareja jean claude de nan de gibbon
había convertido objetos y naturalezas
de gran tamaño en arte empaquetado por
telas pero el máximo símbolo francés
junto a la torre eiffel no eran botes o
barriles o la costa australiana de
little bay
la alcaldía le denegó el proyecto hasta
pocos meses antes de su muerte en mayo
de 2020 cuando obtuvo los permisos
finales de ahí que hablemos de un sueño
que se ha hecho realidad aún de manera
póstuma y gracias a la promesa de su
sobrino vladimir para él como encargado
de la instalación este proyecto es la
consecución del sueño de cristo para un
amigo dramaturgo fernando arrabal es el
triunfo del gran arte contra las
circunstancias
a nosotros nos recuerda que lo efímero
juega un rol en el arte cambia la
estética de monumentos así interroga
sobre su permanencia y entretiene porque
pese a temporal ésta es la gran
atracción del momento y el dúo desde el
más allá sonríe feliz
hasta el 3 de octubre el arco de triunfo
de parís lucirán nuevas prendas
estas enormes telas de polipropileno
reciclable de color plateado y azul y
sujetas con tres mil metros de cuerda
roja están al servicio de una de las
mayores instalaciones de la pandemia se
podría decir que el despliegue de sus 25
mil metros cuadrados de vestimenta
inició con un equipo de escaladores sin
embargo la realidad de esta envoltura
surgió hace 60 años de la visión de la
pareja de artistas christo y
jeanne-claude
fallecidos en 2020 y 2009
respectivamente hoy es su sobrino
vladimir el que da vida póstuma a este
reto de 14 millones de euros recaudados
en su totalidad de la venta de otras
obras planos y bocetos
completely
sainz burst como saben esto fue
completamente diseñado por cristo hasta
el último detalle y probablemente yo sea
una de las pocas personas conocedoras de
todos los detalles porque estuve tanto
tiempo con él hablando tanto sobre esto
hemos querido hacer lo que cristo le
hubiera gustado que fuera
se ha instalado una estructura metálica
sobre un edificio catalogado de
monumento histórico tomando todas las
medidas para no dañar las estatuas las
cornisas y los elementos del arco
triunfal el desafío técnico ha sido
gestionar esto en muy poco tiempo
empezamos el 15 de julio y el
desmantelamiento debe concluir antes de
las ceremonias del 11 de noviembre por
vermont al monte cristo nacido de
bulgaria en 1935 no impregnaba mucho
sentimiento a su arte más bien buscaba
junto a jean-claude la belleza desde
este arco de triunfo dibujado en sus
cuadernos hasta la mítica cobertura en
1985 del puente pugna pasando por el
edificio de reyes está que diez años
después hizo igualmente célebre al
central park con siete mil quinientos
tres puertas de nylon
para parís esto es genial el arco del
triunfo es parís y todo el mundo podrá
verlo criticarlo le gustará o no el arte
es para todos y cada uno hace de él lo
que quiere es un envoltorio bastante
extraordinario tengo 60 años y me
recuerda al pop un acontecimiento mágico
de quedarme decepcionado desde un lado y
primero una tela argentada azul a
contraluz un poco gris y luego la vi con
luz magnífica claro y me a veces se
magnifican los visitantes que se ubiquen
en las fachadas al pie del arco podrán
tocar la tela y hasta llevarse un trozo
del montaje y quienes suban a la cima
también la pisarán respetando el último
deseo del dúo más gigantesco del arte
[Música]
de los arcos asume su origen romano de
victoria de festejo a una o varias
figuras pero de las estatuas ya no se
toleran símbolos cuestionables dando
lugar a grandes polémicas en ciudad de
méxico se logró bajo excusa de
restauración retirar a cristóbal colón'
del paseo de la reforma pero las
críticas no han cesado aún con pedro
reyes sustituyéndola por una obra en
piedra en honor a las mujeres indígenas
más de 350 personalidades consideran que
alguien no auto identificado como tal no
debe crearla por lo que el gobierno
local ha apartado ahora el escultor y
será el comité de monumentos el que
decidirá quién la concluirá
y queremos agradecer al arquitecto pedro
reyes porque realmente
él lo tomo como algo fundamental y es
muy probable que también parte de su
obra éste también exponiéndose en la
ciudad si esto puede ser subjetivo que
piensan de la quema de libros de astérix
tintín o lucky luke debidos a ofensa a
los pueblos americanos es lo que se ha
sabido que ocurrió en 2019 en una
asociación de escuelas católicas de
canadá que lanzó a las llamas y al
reciclaje a casi cinco mil títulos
infantiles novelas y enciclopedias por
discriminatorias esto en un gesto de
reconciliación y contra los prejuicios
indígenas el revisionismo la cancelación
pasa por la destrucción
no nos apartamos del debate aunque más
por el fondo que por la forma ya que fue
una celebración que el leve no moma el
acontecimiento dirigida por otra dione
se alzara con el león de oro a la mejor
cinta de la mostra mientras jane campion
se lucía en dirección y penélope cruz
hacía lo propio como la primera actriz
española en ganar la copa volpi sin
obviar al palmarés masculino 1 las
últimas grandes citas de premios han
estado lideradas por mujeres y dos ojo
con el cine francés porque con titan en
kan la industria se suma otro tanto
gracias a su cuidado y para el caso esta
adaptación de la novela de anne ya no
pinta a joya como lo es su título
en ambas creaciones se aborda como en
los 60 una joven queda embarazada
convencida de su derecho al aborto en
una francia que lo prohibía en el libro
de esta primera persona externo su
experiencia propia en la película 'la su
firmeza por llevar a cabo esta práctica
es casi otro personaje a pesar de la
dureza de su decisión y la soledad de la
clandestinidad existe lo preguntan si
este es un alegato a favor más que del
aborto al feminismo ya que las mujeres
decidan ya que deje de sestao en la
pantalla poniéndonos en la piel de la
intérprete anamaría un parto lo menos
que al inicio me chocó bastante la
diferencia entre lo que creía del aborto
clandestino y lo que descubrí sobre la
realidad de este proceso luego lo que me
gusta de la escritura de snow es ese
estilo puro y muy visceral y en mi nació
un deseo de encarnación tengo la suerte
de vivir en el siglo 21 tener derechos
que bueno son frágiles pero los defendí
con la máxima fuerza posible porque es
terrible el personaje debe elegir entre
sus estudios su carrera o su vida es
injusto
preciso otra adaptación estrenada
igualmente en venecia nos adentra en las
series esta se presenta a sí misma a
través de los afiches de hoy y de 1973
cuando con tonos pastel y planos
teatrales y marc berman desnude las
escenas de la vida conyugal disparando
los divorcios en su suecia no es el
propósito del actual ministerio del
israelí gai levy pero sus secretos de un
matrimonio incómoda y maravilla a partes
iguales beige vio gusta porque los
herederos de esta obra jessica chastain
y oscar isaac llenan de realismo la
cruda exposición de un amor de 12 años
casados y con una hija es no obstante
tras un aborto que el remake nos sumerge
en el divorcio las frustraciones el
vacío y los egos con una actualización
al poliamor los roles y la tecnología es
ahí donde esta disección que inicia en
pleno rodaje se vuelve irritante porque
al final son dos seres amándose
culpándose reconciliándose en
desgastándose como hacemos en nuestras
relaciones
[Música]
efe
por qué
[Música]
en otro registro de crímenes y
detectives tipo juego club o credo es
solo asesinatos en el edificio no sé a
ustedes pero mi predisposición para esta
serie fueron los legendarios steve
martin y martín short y no es azar que
haya renovado una segunda temporada
short luce divertidísimo y la idea de
hallar al culpable entre los vecinos de
un bloque de nueva york mientras montan
un podcast junto a la sospechosa selena
gomez funcionan la idea de steve revive
el espíritu de las comedias de los 80 90
[Música]
el último título de nuestras elecciones
se descubre el pronunciar mails y otis y
hasta aquí el tercer regreso a las
clases de moore del que agrandó el
fervor sexual y recoge las consecuencias
de los consejos y traumas pasados ahí
entra en mi cambiada debido a su
opresión pero también una nueva temible
directora ya no embarazada y un
estudiante y no binario en general hay
una transformación total de los
personajes magdalenas en forma de vulva
y mucha confianza entendida dentro de la
diversidad
y
ahora bien yo creo suelo
[Música]
y a modo de cierre una de las notas
musicales de la semana la entona la
cantautora arlo parks por su voz y unas
letras comprometidas con temas como el
género y la salud mental consiguió
recientemente el premio mercury al mejor
álbum del año en reino unido e irlanda
su nombre collapse en zombies
si yo
[Música]
el lugar
haciendo
y más
si vienes con la quietud del presente de
la hora que decimos hasta pronto por
cortesía de bomba estéreo con su álbum
de jai con sonidos naturales de aves y
olas li saumet y simón mejía nos invitan
a conectarnos al planeta y a lo humano a
nosotros mismos cuídense y gracias por
la compañía gracias
por el pensamiento
[Música]
y
también los sueños
retira
[Música]
[Aplausos]
sí